Mein Name ist Ekrem Özgüvali. Ich bin auch in dieser Station als Arslanast tätig.
Würde ich gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen. Alles in Ordnung für Sie?
Guten Tag Herr Doktor. Ehrlich gesagt geht es mir nicht so gut. Ich habe hier wirklich lange gewartet. Wie kommt es denn eigentlich, dass man so lange warten muss?
Ja, ich verstehe Ihre Sorge, dass Sie so viel erwarten müssen. Aber wir haben in der Notfall einen dringenden Notfall.
Deswegen müssen wir zunächst noch andere Notfallpatienten behandeln. Ich werde Ihnen sofort interessieren.
Okay, na gut.
Und wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder Fragen haben, lassen Sie es mich bitte wissen. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Silvia Hamas.
Silvia Hamas.
Hamas. Am Ende gibt es.
Können Sie bitte das Fahnen und Nachnamen langsam beschreiben?
Natürlich Herr Doktor.
Silvia ist S-I-L-V-I-A.
Okay.
Und Hamas H-A-M-E-L-S.
Hamas. Frau Hamas, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 63 Jahre alt.
Wann genau ist Sie geboren?
Herr Doktor, am 24.12.1963.
Noch einmal bitte.
Ich bin am 24.12.1963 geboren.
Okay, vielen Dank. Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Hamas?
Herr Doktor, 1 Meter 87.
Wie viel wiegen Sie, Frau Hamas?
Etwa 89 Kiloherz.
Frau Hamas, was für Sie ist heute?
Ich habe seit drei Tagen starke Kopfschmerzen, Herr Doktor.
Drei Tage starke Kopfschmerzen.
Wo genau haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Beide Seiten im Schlafbereich.
Beide Seiten im Schlafbereich. Okay.
Frau Hamas, strallen die Schmerzen irgendwann aus?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Strallen nicht die Schmerzen. Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen langsam oder plötzlich aufgetreten?
Langsam.
Langsam aufgetreten? Vor drei Tagen?
Die Schmerzen langsam aufgetreten?
Wie begenen Sie diese Schmerzen?
Stichend, brennend, sehend, dumpf, klopfend?
Es ist klopfend und pulsierend.
Es fühlt sich wirklich so an,
als würde jemand mit einem Hammer auf meinen Kopf schlagen, Herr Doktor.
Wie ein Hammer. Okay.
Wie Hammer schlagen. Okay. Ich verstehe.
Ich meine, Kopfschmerzen.
Ja, ich verstehe, dass Sie sehr, sehr starke Schmerzen haben im Moment.
Wie beschreiben Sie, wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala,
nur kein Schmerzen, sehr, sehr starke Schmerzen bedeutet?
Wie beschreiben Sie Ihre Schmerzen?
Ja, morgens etwa bei sechs.
Aber abends wird es schlimmer.
Ungefähr acht von zehn, Herr Doktor.
Acht von fünf. Abends. Aber morgens sechs.
Im Moment?
Ja, vielleicht. Ja, in diesem Moment würde ich sagen acht. Entschuldigung, sechs.
Brauchen Sie eine Schmerzmittele?
Lieber, Herr Doktor.
Oder können Sie am Ende aushalten?
Wie gesagt, der Vorzüge ist lieber eine Schmerzmittele.
Okay, okay. Haben Sie eine Allergie gegen Allergie?
Ich habe eine Allergie gegen Penisillin, Herr Doktor.
Penisillin, Allergie.
Wie reagieren Sie auf Penisillin?
Auf Rötung, auf Jukras und Rötung, Herr Doktor.
Jukras und Rötung.
Gibt es noch andere Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit?
Gott sei Dank habe ich nicht.
Gut, okay. Ich rufe sofort meine Schwester an und gebe Ihnen eine Schmerzmittele.
Danke.
Können Sie weiterführen?
Ja, natürlich bitte.
Gibt es bestimmte Auflöser für die Schmerzen?
Was meinen Sie? Nein, das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie einen Kopfverletzten?
Nein, Gott nein.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft da oder?
Ja, sie sind dauerhaft da.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen versteckt?
Ja, abends und besonders bei der Arbeit.
Per Schilmacht.
Ja, ja.
Abends und bei der Arbeit. In Ruhe?
Natürlich ist es besser als abends.
Es lindert Sie in Ruhe?
Kann man so sagen.
Aber nicht ganz lindern. Nur teilweise.
Es ist ein Vergleich zu der Arbeit.
Ist das das erste Mal, dass Sie in der Arbeit ein Kiebeschwerden haben?
Ich kann sagen, dass es ein starker erste Mal ist.
Herr Behanz, ist das schon bei Ihren Hausarzt?
Nein Herr Doktor. Aber früher hatte ich immer wieder Kopfschmerzen.
Sie fühlten sich drückend an.
Ungefähr einmal im Monat.
Aber diese Schmerzen sind anders.
Meinen Sie eine chronische Kopfschmerzen?
Ja, ja. Ich meine, so. Immer wieder habe ich einen Kopfschmerzen.
Einmal im Monat.
Aber die Kopfschmerzen, die ich darunter erleide, sind anders als die ich erwähnte.
Ja, okay. Ich verstehe.
Habt ihr dagegen ein Medikament eingenommen?
Ja, ich nehme Ibuprofen. 600 mg.
Ibuprofen. 600 mg.
Aber das hat mir nicht geholfen.
Nicht geholfen?
Mir nicht geholfen, ja.
Frau Hammes, wissen Sie schon, Ibuprofen, 600 mg ist ein Rezeptpflichtmedikament.
Haben Sie noch ein Rezept?
Nein, ehrlich gesagt vom Rezept meines Mannes habe ich das gekriegt.
Ja, das Medikament gehört Ihres Mannes.
Ohne Erdbeutung.
Ja, das mache ich Herr Doktor. Danke für Ihre Achtung.
Bitte achten Sie darauf. Ohne Rezept, ohne Erdbeutung nehmen Sie bitte kein Medikament.
Das ist sehr sehr wichtig für uns.
Frau Hammes, haben Sie noch andere bestimmte Beschwerden?
Zum Beispiel Lehmungen, Hörstörungen, Sehstörungen, Schwindel?
Herr Doktor, ich hatte auch ein anderes Problem. Es gibt schwarze Flecken vor den Augen.
Sie haben vor Augen eine schwarze Flecken. Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Seit wann? Seit gestern kann ich sagen.
Seit gestern. Gibt es noch Hörstörungen?
Nein, Gott sei Dank. Aber das stört mich, diese schwarzen Flecken.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Okay. Haben Sie Fieber, Frau Hammes?
Nein, Herr Doktor. Ich habe nicht.
Nachtschweiß, Kassenschweiß? Schwerze, Ausbruch?
Das habe ich nicht, Herr Doktor.
Okay. Haben Sie schon einmal Bewusstsein verloren oder Bewusstseinsveränderung?
Bewusstsein verloren habe ich nicht. Aber ich fühle mich auch schwindelig, Herr Doktor.
Ja, schwindelig. Seit wann? Seit gestern oder?
Ja, kann ich sagen. Seit gestern.
Seit gestern schwindelig. Okay. Ich habe das notiert.
Und Herzklopfen habe ich seit gestern.
Schwindelig und?
Ja, manchmal Herzklopfen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder Wassalasen?
Beim Stuhlgang oder mit Stuhlgang habe ich keine Probleme. Aber ich muss auf die Toilette häufiger als sonst.
Zu Wassalasen meine ich.
In der letzten Zeit müssen Sie als sonst häufig.
Ja, häufig als sonst. Und ich trinke viel Wasser, Herr Doktor. Ich habe ständig Durst. Etwa drei Liter Wasser am Tag trinke ich.
Wie viel trinken Sie pro Tag?
Etwa drei Liter Wasser.
Drei Liter. Ist das im Azo oder in der letzten Zeit?
In der letzten Zeit.
Okay. Haben Sie eine Schwellung bemerkt? Im Körper zum Beispiel?
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt, Herr Doktor.
Gibt es eine Veränderung beim Urin? Farbveränderung oder Geruch?
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt, aber häufiger als sonst muss ich auf die Toilette.
Okay. Gibt es Blut im Urin oder Stuhlgang?
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay. Frau Homas, schlafen Sie gut?
Ehrlich gesagt kann ich nicht gut schlafen. Wegen dieser Schmerzen und häufiger Toilette, Handtrag, kann ich nicht gut schlafen.
Okay.
Ich bin sehr müde, Herr Doktor.
Okay. Frau Homas, leiden sind irgendeine chronische Erkrankung. Zum Beispiel Rückerkrankung, Bluthochdruck oder zum Beispiel Migraine oder...
Ja, außer diesen Kopfschmerzen leide ich an Diabetes, Zuckerkrankung und Bluthochdruck.
Zuckerkrankung?
Seit acht Jahren leide ich an Zuckerkrankung und seit fünf Jahren an Bluthochdruck.
Ja.
Aber in den letzten drei Jahren nehme ich gegen die Medikamente ein.
In den letzten drei Jahren nehmen Sie gegen Bluthochdruck?
Gegen Bluthochdruck meine ich.
Gegen Bluthochdruck. Okay. Und was nehmen Sie gegen Diabetes? Schieblichstelle oder Medikamente?
Ich nehme dagegen Medformin 500 mg ein. Zweimal pro Tag.
Medformin 500 mg zweimal?
Ja, genau.
Morgen und Abend oder?
Ja, ja. Frühstück und Abendessen.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder?
Natürlich muss ich regelmäßig, aber manchmal vergesse ich das einzunehmen.
Ja, ich verstehe. Und was noch?
Gegen Bluthochdruck nehme ich Ramiplil 5 mg.
Ramiplil 5 mg?
Ja, einmal. Und Magnesium nehme ich regelmäßig einmal pro Tag.
Und bei Bedarf nehme ich gegen diese Kopfschmerzen Ibuprofen 600 mg ein.
Ibuprofen 600 mg. Bei Bedarf, aber bei Bedarf.
Ja.
Ich würde gerne wissen Frau Hamas, warum nehmen Sie Magnesium?
Gibt es noch eine Erste Scherzrate oder Medikamenten?
Mein Hausarzt hat empfohlen, weil ich Diabetes oder weil ich eine Suche Krankheit habe.
Er hat empfohlen.
Sehr gut.
Frau Hamas, würden Sie schon mal operieren?
Herr Doktor, mir wurde vor etwa 10 Jahren die Gallenblase entfernt.
Gallenblase entfernt? Das war komplikationlos oder?
Ja, es war eine Bauchspiegelung. Sie sind durch meine Nadel gegangen. Ich habe kaum eine Narbe.
Okay, ich verstehe. Meine sind laparoskopisch.
Ja, die Ersten nennen es so.
Sehr gut. Gibt es noch andere Operationen?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Okay, nur Gallenblase entfernt.
Okay.
Und Sie haben noch gesagt, Sie haben eine Penisallergie.
Ja.
Und Frau Hamas, rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich bin nicht Raucher. Ich bin stolz darauf, dass ich nie geraucht habe.
Okay. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nur gerächtlich, Herr Doktor. Zwei Gläser Prozeko oder Wein alle zwei Wochen.
Prozeko? Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich. Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie einmal Drogen ausprobieren?
Herr Doktor, ich rauche keine Zigarette. Sehe ich so aus, dass ich drogabhängig bin?
Nein, bitte denken Sie so nicht, Frau Hamas. Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Weil manche Drogen mit bestimmten Medikamenten Nebenwirkungen oder Wegseilwirkungen haben können.
Deswegen frage ich.
Ach so, Sie haben recht.
Eine Routinefrage.
Ich brauche keinen Kontakt.
Frau Hamas, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Herr Doktor, leider ist mein Vater an Pneumokoniosis verstorben. Sie sagen so, Pneumokoniosis, Staublunge.
Wissen Sie?
Verstorben. Wegen Pneumokoniosis?
Staublunge, ja. Sie sagen Pneumokoniosis. Währenddessen konnte ich das erfahren. Deswegen so gesagt.
Warum ist Herr Doktor daran verstorben?
War er ein Bergwerker?
Ja, er war Bergwerker.
Deswegen Frau Hamas, das ist eine chronische, endspontliche Lungenerkrankung. Natürlich sehr gefährlich. Es tut mir leid.
Das war für uns sehr traurig.
Und Ihre Mutter?
Sie war sehr jung.
Ihre Mutter?
Ja, Gott sei Dank lebt meine Mutter noch. Aber sie hat Kniegelenkartose.
Knieprobleme.
Kniegelenkartose, ok.
Sie haben Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe vier Geschwister. Eine davon ist gestorben, leider, Herr Doktor.
Eine gestorben?
Ja, letztes Jahr. An einem Herzenfall.
Es tut mir sehr leid. Mein herzliches Beileid für Ihre Verlust.
Gott sei Dank sind die anderen gesund.
Gott sei Dank. Und Frau Hamas, was machen Sie?
Herr Doktor, ich bin Betriebsbuchhalterin.
Betriebsbuchhalterin. Verheiratet ihr?
Ich bin verheiratet und wohne mit meinem Ehemann zusammen.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben zwei Töchter, Herr Doktor. Sie sind Gott sei Dank gesund.
Ok, mein Freund.
Frau Hamas, Sie haben seit acht Jahren Diabetes, Rückerkrankheit und seit fünf Jahren Arterie für Patronien.
Ja, genau.
Und was machen Sie für diese Krankheit? Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Ihre Medikamentei?
Zum Beispiel haben Sie schon gesagt, nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamentei, 500 mg. Aber wann war letztes Mal Blutstuckerkontrolle?
Herr Doktor, leider habe ich seit mehreren Tagen keine Teststreifen.
Ich wollte das verschreiben lassen, aber weil meine Hausarztpraxis seit zwei Wochen geschlossen ist, konnte ich das nicht schaffen.
Vor 15 Tagen war der Blutzucker erhöht.
Wurde er gemessen?
Vor 15 Tagen habe ich das gemessen, aber war er erhöht.
Könnten Sie mir vielleicht ein Blutzucker-Messgerät verschreiben?
Ja, natürlich.
Oder diese Teststreifen geben Sie mir?
Oder ein Blutzucker-Messgerät.
Nein, ein Blutzucker-Messgerät.
Ich meine, ein Blutzucker-Messgerät.
Ein Blutzucker-Messgerät kann ich Ihnen verschreiben.
Aber für den Blutzuckerstreifen brauchen Sie keine Rezept.
Ohne Rezept können Sie ihn in der Apotheke kaufen.
Ich habe gerade das erfahren.
Okay, ich mache so. Bei der Apotheke kann ich diese Teststreifen kaufen.
Ja, wissen Sie, Frau Hammers, das sollte regelmäßig kontrolliert werden.
Sehr wichtig für uns.
Alles gut, Frau Menemans. Ich habe einen Verdacht auf Sie.
Herr Doktor, meine Blutdruckwerte sind ein bisschen erhöht.
Gestern war es 150 zu 80 und heute Morgen 180 zu 90.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Vielleicht möchten Sie wissen. Deswegen habe ich gesagt.
Ja, sehr wichtig für uns.
Ich habe einen Verdacht auf Sie. Unkontrollierte Zuckerkrankheit und Bluthochdruck.
Deswegen werde ich zuerst Ihren Körper untersuchen.
Dann ein wenig Blut abnehmen.
Für das Labor, das besteht ein paar Untersuchungen.
Und dann eine Summe. Vielleicht brauchen wir ein paar entokonologische und kardiologische Konzill.
Bitte warten Sie hier.
Ja, Herr Doktor, ich warte auf Sie.
Ich bin mit meinem Obers und komme zurück.
So ist das für mich.
Okay.
Bis gleich, oder?
Ja, bis gleich.
Frau Obers.
Ich brauche eine Laboanruf.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
Möchtest du eine Anruf machen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Können Sie mir eine Frage stellen?
Die Diabetes-Mellotus ist ein Typ.
Kann man verstehen, dass die Diabetes-Mellotus im aktuellen Anamnesis eine Typ ist?
Oder müssen wir die Anamnesis im Core-Erkrankungs-Tip ansehen?
Also, man kann sich an die aktuellen Anamnesen und die Wegetatib-Anamnesen befassen.
Man kann sich an die aktuellen Anamnesen und die Wegetatib-Anamnesen befassen.
Die Diabetes-Mellotus sind die Symptome des Kopfschmerzens oder der Schwindel.
Aber man kann es in der Anamnesis lernen.
Man kann sich an die Anamnesis lernen, ob die Diabetes-Mellotus in der Anamnesis kontrolliert oder nicht.
Okay, danke.
Normalerweise, wenn ein Patient in einem Kurs eine solche Anmerkung hat,
dann sagt er, dass er viel Wasser trinkt.
Wir fragen direkt.
Wir hatten direkt gefragt, ob wir an der Anamnesis des Core-Erkrankungs-Tips warten würden,
ob wir eine chronische Analyse haben.
Deswegen stellen wir uns nicht vor, das zu fragen.
Wir fragen an der Anamnesis des Core-Erkrankungs-Tips.
Ich hoffe, dass es eine Antwort gibt.
Danke.
Jetzt haben Sie mit Kopfschmerzen angefangen, aber nicht mit Polyurepolydikten.
Das Patient kommt mit Kopfschmerzen.
Denn das ist die Grundlage.
Der Patient spielt nicht die Rolle, weil er zu viel schläft oder zu viel in die Toilette geht.
Deswegen?
Ich frage mich, ob es andere Dinge gibt,
denn bei anderen Patienten, die an einer Anamnesis sind,
kannst du die Tipps ausmachen,
aber hier kannst du es nur mit dem Core-Erkrankungs-Tip fangen.
Nein, mit der Vaginative Anamnese kannst du es auch fangen.
Es gibt eine Zufallung.
Der Patient sagt, dass er sehr schläft und sehr schläft.
Du kannst von dort aus zufallend sein.
Die Diabetes Mellitus-Pilz sagt, dass es ein Diabetes Mellitus-Pilz sein kann.
Dieser Patient, der Diabetes Mellitus-Pilz,
spielt die Rolle so.
Er kommt immer mit Kopfschmerzen.
Kopfschmerzen und Schwarzefohraufgaben oder Fleckefohraufgaben,
die vor dem Gesicht, die Schleifkörbe, Flecke, Flemme,
kommen mit dem Patient.
Meyra Hocam.
Ich bin es.
Meyra Hocam, wenn du mir das okay machst,
habe ich zwei Merkungen, wie das hier in Danis.
Vielleicht kann ich das schnell machen.
Ich möchte ein paar Sachen sagen.
Natürlich, Meyra Hocam.
Kann ich das machen?
Natürlich.
Ich habe auch eine Schwindelung im Kohlschrank.
Das kann sein.
Aber der Patient hat mir wohl gesagt, dass ich da nicht in die Schleife gehen soll.
Fliemenforden-Augen sind generell
die Lichtblasen, die im Hiboglizum-Atau gesehen werden.
Ich habe das gefunden.
Ich werde jetzt die Fakten anzeigen.
Ja, man sieht Hiboglizum im Schwarzen Flocken.
Aber das ist noch weniger.
Ich habe die Schwindelung im Kohlschrank aus dem Boot gefragt.
Ich habe die Schwindelung im Kohlschrank aus dem Boot gesagt.
Und ich habe den Kohlschrank verpasst.
Und ich habe die Schwindelung aufgeteilt.
Ich versuche das zu sagen, Hocam.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass du die Medizin nicht mehr brauchst.
Du hast die Patientin gesagt.
Dann sagst du, dass du sie nicht mehr brauchst.
Das ist das Ende.
Dann wird sie vielleicht 15-20 Sekunden lang verletzen.
Vielleicht 20-30 Sekunden lang.
Ich habe hier einen Fehler gemacht. Ich habe die Gewichtveränderung nicht gefragt.
Ich habe das vergessen.
Weil ich das auf Kartei schreibe, hat der Arztbrief vorhin die Begriffe gemacht.
Ah, hier war die Gewichtveränderung.
Ich habe sie nicht gefragt. Gut, sie hat nicht gefragt.
Deswegen ist es wichtig, diese Sitzung auf den Chefhekumenten zu schreiben.
Ich habe mit dem Chefhekument nicht ein bisschen verstanden.
Er hat mir die Hypo-Kaleme gefragt.
Ich habe nicht wissen können, wie man die Hekimisse nicht wissen kann.
Ich kann es nicht wissen, aber ich kann die Mechanismen ausmachen,
das hat er mir gesagt.
Er hat mich nicht gefragt.
Ich konnte es nicht sagen, dass ich das normalerweise nicht sage.
Ich habe es gesagt, aber es war nicht so klar.
Aber das war das Grund.
Ich habe den Patienten schuldig gesucht.
Ein Labor-Kommission war da.
Er hat mich gefragt, was ich tun soll.
Ich hätte gesagt, ich würde die Metformine klettern.
Ich habe hier viele Leute, aber ich sage es schüchtern.
Ich habe sie nicht gefragt.
Aber wie gesagt, ich habe Fehler gemacht.
Es war nicht so.
Ich muss es auf der anderen Seite wiederholen.
Es ist nicht wichtig.
Die Ziel ist es, zu sprechen.
Ich will nicht überlegen, ob es etwas gibt,
das uns nicht an die Hände hält.
Aber es kann nicht sein.
Die Jungs haben sich selbstvertrauen.
Die Jungs arbeiten jeden Tag 10-15 Stunden.
Sie lassen das, weil sie sich stolz auf sie sind.
Ich liebe das Wort von Sümeyra.
Wir werden auf die Stellen, wo wir kontrollieren können,
schauen und auf unsere Wege gehen.
Wir gehen weiter.
Okay.
Hallo, Ökologin.
Guten Tag.
Ich bin Frau Ypik.
Frau Redel, Hemoglobinwert, ist 5,23 Gramm pro Dessiliter.
5,23.
2,2.
Gramm pro Dessiliter Frau Redel.
R-E-D-E-L.
Okay, verstehe.
Könnten Sie bitte diese Worte weiterleiten?
Okay, vielen Dank, Frau Ypik.
Okay, schönen Tag.
Ich regne das.
Schönen Tag.
Guten Tag, Herr Özyuvalı.
Woher kommen Sie?
Frau Oğarsın, ich komme aus der Türkei.
Seit wann sind Sie in Deutschland?
Ca. 3 Jahre bin ich in Deutschland.
Ich lebe in Deutschland mit meiner Familie.
Meine Frau und meine Kinder.
Warum sind Sie nach Deutschland gekommen?
Eine große Herausforderung.
Wir sind hier vor 3 Jahren wegen der politischen Gründe.
Wegen der politischen Gründe müssen wir nach Deutschland auswanderen.
Okay.
Was haben Sie bisher gemacht in Deutschland?
Bisher haben wir Deutschlands auswanderen.
Wir haben Deutschlands auswanderen.
Okay.
Was haben Sie bisher gemacht in Deutschland?
Bisher haben wir Deutschlands auswanderen.
B1, B2 und Fachsprache.
Sie sprechen immer wie?
Warum?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Wie? Wir.
Sie meinen Sie und Ihre Familie?
Meine Familie, ja.
Alle Familien.
Alle Familien machen Sie zusammen einen Kurs?
Alle Familien machen wir einen Kurs.
Die Kinder bei der Schule.
Ich und meine Frau.
Bei dem Kurs.
Wir lernen alle seit 3 Jahren Deutsch.
Kein anderes Thema.
Aber dass Ihre Kinder schon Deutsch sehr gut?
Die Kinder waren super.
Ihre Frau ist auch Ärztin?
Ja.
Die Reaktation und Therapie.
Er ist Ärztin.
Hat Sie schon die Fachsprachprüfung bestanden?
Nein, leider noch nicht.
Okay.
Später haben Sie Ihre Frau
und helfen Sie Ihrer Frau?
Während der Vorbereitung?
Ja, natürlich.
Okay. Was haben Sie heute für uns?
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten.
Aber bevor ich meinen Patienten vorstelle,
möchte ich Ihnen etwas wichtiges mitteilen.
Gerade aus dem Labor.
Frau Ipek hat mich angerufen.
Sie berichtete, dass Frau Redel
einen Hemoglobinwert 5,23 Gramm pro Dessiliter hat.
Diese Werte sind deutlich erniedrigt.
Eine Anzahl von 5,23 Gramm.
Das ist ein sehr grosser Wert.
Okay.
Welche Art von Anime wissen Sie?
Oder wie viele Art von Anime gibt es?
Anime Klassifierung.
Makro Sitter oder Micro Sitter
Und die Mikrosite, die Normasite.
Wie können Sie entscheiden, welche Art von Anemie?
Ich habe 1000 Korpuskular Volumen und 1000 Korpuskular Enermikniten.
Und ich habe LdV, Retikulosid-Differenzation.
Was ist der Normausbereich von MCF?
Der Normausbereich MCF ist, soweit ich mich erinnere, 32 und 38.
MCF liegt zwischen 83 bis 96 Fnt.
96, ja. Vielen Dank für die Information.
83, 96 Fnt.
Fnt? Ich habe das erstmals gehört.
Okay. Wissen Sie weitere Ursachen?
Herr Oberstin, sollen wir für die Prüfung so vorbereiten?
Zum Beispiel diese Weise habe ich nicht.
Wie gesagt, das letzte Mal habe ich diese Kenntnisse in der Medizinstudium gesehen oder gelesen.
Ich glaube, dass Sie diese Information mit Ihrem Oberarzt oder Oberarztin nicht mitteilen.
Sie können einfach, ah, im Moment fällt mir gerade nichts ein.
Vielen Dank für die Information und können Sie weiter.
Ich bereite diese Prüfung wie eine Sprachprüfung.
Deswegen habe ich keine medizinische Kenntnisse außer in der LdV.
Du hast Recht, das ist eine Sprachprüfung.
Du musst diese Information nicht auf jeden Fall wissen.
Aber du kannst diese Frage bekommen.
Und dann, obwohl du diese Information nicht wusst, kannst du auf jeden Fall eine Antwort geben.
Zum Beispiel, momentan fällt mir dazu nichts ein.
Ich habe schon gelesen, aber leider kann ich momentan nicht daran erinnern,
dass es auch eine Antwort, eine sprachliche Antwort gibt.
Ja, super.
Super, Entschuldigung.
Ihr habt alle Informationen gelesen.
Ja, ich habe das gelesen, aber aktuell fällt mir nichts ein.
Deswegen entschuldigen Sie mich.
Was haben Sie noch heute für uns?
Ja, ich habe einen neuen Patienten.
Es geht um Frau Sylvia Hamas.
Sie ist 63 Jahre alt, geboren am 24.12.1963.
Sie ist 1,87 Meter groß.
Ich weiss nicht, ob diese Weise richtig ist.
Sie ist 89 Kilo.
Sylvia Hamas, Frau Hamas stellt sich heute bei uns seit drei Tagen
stärkere Kopfschmerzen beidesseits im temporalen Bereich vor.
Die Schmerzen strahlen nicht aus.
Laut Angaben der Patienten sind die Schmerzen langsam aufgetreten.
Sind die Schmerzen?
Ja, sind die Schmerzen vor drei Tagen langsam aufgetreten.
Sie berichten, dass Schmerzen klopfen wie ein Hama schlagen.
Entschuldigung, Sie berichten, dass Schmerzen wie Hama schlagen sind.
Wie Hama schlagen sind, ja.
Momentan korrigiere ich Ihre Grammatikfehler.
Ihre Satze sind schön, das gefällt mir.
Aber es gibt ein paar Grammatikfehler.
Sie berichtet, dass die Schmerzen wie ein Hama schlagen sind.
Die Schmerzen sind klopfend und drückend.
Schmerzintensität liegt bei morgens acht von zehn.
Am abends und bei der Arbeit liegt bei acht von zehn.
Dagegen nimmt sie bei Bedarf Ibuprofen 600 mg.
Aber das hat ein bisschen geholfen für die Schmerzen.
In der letzten Zeit, seit gestern Abend, das hat nicht geholfen.
Seit drei Tagen sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft.
Die Schmerzen verstärken sich bei der Arbeit.
Und abends lindert die Schmerzen in Ruhe.
Sie bildet auch, seit gestern hat sie vor Augen Schmerzen pflegen.
Und ist ihnen schwindelig.
Bei der Vorerkrankung an Amnese ergaben sich eine chronische Kopfschmerzen.
Ich möchte erst mal den Vegetativeanruf sagen.
Seit drei Tagen ist sie schwindelig.
Sie hat Schlafstörungen und Herzstolpern.
Sie fühlt sich häufig durch.
Sie hat ca. drei Liter pro Tag getrunken.
Sie hat wegen der Schmerzen eine dauerhafte Schlafstörung.
Bei der Vorerkrankung an Amnese ergaben sich eine chronische Kopfschmerzen.
Sie hat acht Jahre Diabetes mellitus, Typ 2.
Dagegen nimmt sie mit Formen 500 mg täglich morgens und abends.
Sie kann sich die Vegetative an Amnese ausdrücken.
Vegetative an Amnese ergab sich Polydipsy, Polyüri.
Ja, Polyüri.
Schmerzbedingte Schlafstörungen oder schmerzbedingte Schmerzen?
Wo gibt es noch?
Und Schwindelig, Schlafstörungen auch.
Alle vegetative Symptome können Sie in einem Satz nennen.
Vegetative Anamnestisch, Ergapsyke, Polydipsy, Polyure, Klopfen, Schwindel.
Schmerzbedingte Schlafstörungen in der Appetanz.
Bei der Vorerkrankung an amnese Erbente sie seit acht Jahren Diabetes-Meditators Typ 2 und seit fünf Jahren Ateleliphytonin und anekronische Kopfschmerzen.
Ist Ihr Blutzucker gut eingestellt?
Nein, leider nicht. Er nimmt ihre Medikamente nicht regelmäßig.
Sie nimmt ihre Medikamente nicht regelmäßig.
Wann wurde Ihr Blutzucker das letzte Mal gemessen?
Vor fünf Tagen.
Sie hat ihr Blutzucker gemessen. Sie hat gesagt, ich habe das nicht nutziert.
Sie hatte auch eine unkontrollierte Ateleliphytonin. Die letzte Messung war 180 mmHg.
Sie wurde gemessen.
Wegen Ateleliphytonin, Ramiplil 5 mg täglich einmal.
Magnesium Tablet und Klaredosis täglich einmal und Ibuprofen 600 mg bei Bedarf.
Vor zehn Jahren hatte sie eine Voroperation.
Bei ihr wurde Galenblase entfannt.
Was ist der Fachbegriff?
Cholestectomy. Sie ist nicht Raucherin. Sie trinkt am Wochenende zwei Gläser Wein und Drogen konsumiert.
Sie trinkt?
Sie trinkt am Wochenende zwei Gläser Wein und Drogen konsumiert.
Die Drogenkonsumierung wurde verleint.
Die Familienanamnese ergab Pneumokonios bei dem Vater.
Dagen verstorben ist.
Die Mutter hatte eine kniggelenkte Erkrankung.
Konarthros?
Konarthros, ja.
Sie hat vier Schwestern.
Eine Schwestern ist wegen einem Herzinfarkt, Miochardinfarkt, verstorben.
Sie ist Betriebsbuchhalterin und lebt zusammen mit ihrer Familie.
Sie hat zwei Töchter. Sie ist gesund.
Sie sind gesund?
Sie sind gesund.
Aufgrund der Anamnese habe ich den Verdacht auf Stoffwechselerkrankung aufgrund Diabetes mellitus und unkontrollierter arteriöler Hypatonie,
Kopfschmerzen, Duft, Testtoten und Schlafstörungen und was soll ich sagen?
Polydipsy, Polyüri.
Polydipsy, Polyüri, entspricht dafür.
Die Vorgeschichte?
Die Vorgeschichte, ja.
Diabetes mellitus, Typ 2 und arteriöler Hypatonie, sprechen dafür?
Ja, sprechen dafür.
Und die Differenz der Diaktose ist, dass sie nicht kommen, migrieren und eine trans-isemische Attacke betrachten.
Ich werde zunächst eine körperliche Untersuchendurchführung und dann Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Im Labor Blutbild Leber und Nierenwerte und Entsundungwerte und CAP, Chemoglobin, A1c und Übrigenstatus kontrollieren.
Dann eine C-T-Schede und eine entnologische und neurologische Konzilanforderung.
Als Initialtherapie würde ich gerne empfehlen, zunächst Physikalsphore und Elektrolystikation.
Und Ernährung, Anstellung und Antihypertension und Antidiabetik werden eingestellt.
Dann Passien-Schulung empfehle ich.
Okay. Vielen Dank.
Ich muss meine Säule aufräumen. Ich kann sie nicht so wie ich sie mir in der Kopfkarte vorstelle.
Aber ich werde sie aufräumen.
Das ist nur das, was Sie an der Stelle anräumen.
Sie müssen nicht vergessen, dass sie eine Helferin sind.
Die Zimt, die Haken, die Lagen.
Und wenn Sie keine Helferin sind, dann müssen Sie die Hände nicht aufräumen.
Sie sind immer am Ende der Säule.
Aber manchmal sind Sie nicht am Ende der Säule.
Ich kann es nicht erinnern.
Ich habe es vorhin schon gesagt, dass wir uns auf die Musikstelle vorbereiten.
Ich habe es im Jahr 2004 gesehen.
Ich kann es nicht erinnern.
Wir haben immer so die Säule.
Ich ganz digital aus der Kamera sieben oder sieben.
Alle stehen so alike.
alten war jeder.
Ich versuche mir die Format auszu4ühren.
Beides wird ich nicht tun.
Ich fahre an, czy werde ich nicht tun.
Dann weiß ich es dringend.
Das Nominat ain.
So auchno ist besser.
Ich gehe jetzt sehr rein他們.
Es ist nicht so schrecklich, dass man das so ausdrücklich nennt.
Nur wenn man sich auf die Tatsachen beachten kann.
Hier, Chetin, du kannst etwas sagen.
Ich wollte auch etwas fragen.
In der Dokumentation, in der Anamnesbogen,
in der Sprache, in der die Sphärische Stimme beginnt,
habe ich die Symptome der Sphärische Stimme geschrieben.
Ich habe Symptome der Sphärische Stimme geschrieben.
Begleitend, Klack, Zyuba, bla bla bla.
Begleitend, oder?
Begleitend, Anamnestisch, Ergab.
Die Megatathese Anamnese Ergab.
Das ist nicht begleitend, aber es kann zwischen Begleitenden sein.
Was ist es? Inzomnes ist es.
Das ist eine lange Zeit.
Du fragst den Patienten,
ich schreibe die Polydipsie, Polyuree in Begleitend.
Ich habe es auch in der letzten Begleitend-Ansage beantwortet.
Ich habe es so verstanden.
Wenn du es in der Begleitend-Ansage erzählen würdest,
dann würde ich es auch in der Begleitend-Ansage beantworten.
Wenn du die Begleitend-Anamnese-Sprache fragst,
dann ist es sehr spezifisch.
Es hilft dir, diese zu kennen.
Dann nenne dich die Begleitend-Anamnese.
Du solltest es in Begleitend-Symptomen sagen.
Ich habe hier Ekrem abgesprochen.
Er hat 5-6 Sätze gesagt, um die Begleitend-Anamnese zu versprechen.
Wie kann er das in einer Session erzählen?
Um das zu zeigen.
Er kann Begleitend-Ansagen benutzen.
Um das zu zeigen, was er weiß.
Und um das in einer Session zu erzählen.
Aber normalerweise ist Polydipsie, Polyuree
hier ein Begleitend-Symptom.
Das ist besser.
Es ist nicht falsch, das in Begleitend-Anamnese zu erzählen.
Aber ich würde das Patienten so erzählen.
Ich würde das Patienten so erzählen.
Die Patienten stellen sich bei uns wegen,
seit drei Tagen,
bestehende Kopfschmerzen
im temporalen Bereich vor.
Laut Aussage,
die Patienten sind die Schmerzen
langsam aufgetreten.
Sie berichten, dass die Schmerzen
wie Hama schlagen und persistieren.
Progredient sind die Schmerzen in der Begleitend-Anamnese.
Sie berichten, dass die Schmerzen
wie Hama schlagen und persistieren.
Progredient sind die Schmerzen in der Begleitend-Anamnese.
Die Schmerzen in der Begleitend-Anamnese
liegen bei
6.10 Uhr morgens
und
8.10 Uhr abends.
Und begleitet klagt sie
über
Photopsie,
oder Flaken vor den Augen.
Oder
begleitet klagt sie
über Photopsie,
oder Flaken vor den Augen.
Die Schmerzen
liegen bei
5.10 Uhr morgens
und
begleitet klagt sie
über
Photopsie,
oder
eingefallen von
Photopsie,
oder
begleitet klagt sie
Melitis tip 2 und seit fünf Jahren arterielle Hypertonie. Leider sind die Teststreifen,
ihre Teststreifen seit zwei Wochen ausgegangen. Deswegen hat sie ihren Blutzucker nicht gut
kontrolliert, aber vor 15 Tagen würde ihre Blutzucker von Hausarzt überprüft und das war
damals war der Wert sehr hoch und ihre Blutdruck würde auch nicht gut eingestellt. Heute Morgen
hat sie ihn gemessen und das war 180 zu 90 gibi. So, so weiter geht es.
Gibt es eine bestimmte Auslöse für die Schmerzen? Vielleicht haben sie sich am Kopf verletzt?
Sind die Schmerzen da war Haft oder gehen sie wieder weg? Ist es das Erste oder hatten sie schon
früher eine Symptome? Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen verstärkt oder gibt es etwas,
das die Schmerzen lindert? Aareleilgele können Sie die Schmerzen genaue beschreiben.
Wenn Sie die Schmerzen von FLAGON4 und FLAGON4 annehmen wollen,
dann fragen Sie, ob sie von FLAGON4 und FLAGON4 genaue beschreiben.
Dann fragen Sie, ob sie von BITESITIC genaue beschreiben.
Denn wenn sie von einer Seite genaue beschrieben, dann ist es wichtig, das zu fragen.
Wenn Sie von einer Seite genaue beschreiben, dann ist es wichtig, das zu fragen.
Dann fragen Sie, ob Sie von FLAGON4 genaue beschreiben.
Dann fragen Sie, ob Sie von BITESITIC genaue beschreiben.
Wenn Sie von einer Seite genaue beschreiben, dann ist es wichtig, das zu fragen.
Wenn er von Flakenford die Erkrankung gesagt hat, dann habe ich nicht die Z-Störungen gefragt.
Hier die Hörstörungen, die Aufgefahr, die Lammunerscheinungen, Kribbelstörungen, Teichhalsgeführ,
die Haben, die sind die Neurologischen Fragen.
Die kommen mit Kopch-Mersen, die sind unsere Patienten.
Wenn sie so kommen, dann frage ich die Schwindel, die Beavus-Teinferne-Störungen,
die Z-Störungen, die Hörstörungen, die Sprahstörungen, die alle zusammen frage ich.
Dann frage ich die Lammunerscheinungen, die Kribbelstörungen, die Teichhalsgeführ,
die alle zusammen frage ich.
Dann frage ich die Migren, die Zinsirlicht-Enfindig oder Laut-Enfindig.
Alle Fragen haben einen Ziel.
Das ist ein älterer Patient.
Deswegen habe ich Fiva nicht sofort gefragt.
Aber normalerweise in Kopch-Mersen, um Fiva und Benazid zu verbreiten,
könnt ihr sie auch in der Vagatat von Anamnese fragen.
Aber ich frage diese Fragen generell.
Ich frage die Gruppen, die ich in der Vagatat von Anamnese fragen.
Dann frage ich die Fiva, die Stülpfros, die Kaisersweiss, die Ausbrüche,
die Leidens, die Unterbrüste, die Schmerzen, die Lufnaud, die Engelgefühle, die Herzrasen,
die Weisirapathie, die Inlässteseit, die Abgenomen, die Zugenomen,
das ist nicht gut.
Das kann man auch sagen,
dass sie nicht gut sind, weil sie in den Schmerzen sind.
Um noch empathischer zu werden und um aus einer Esmerzmode zu kommen.
Dann sind es Gastrointestinal System-Listungen.
Man kann es übel nennen, oder übel kreieren.
Wie ist es mit dem Stuhlgang? Gibt es Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
...dann fragt man sich.
Dann sagt man, dass es Probleme beim Wasser hat.
Hier kann man sich selbst beantworten.
Wenn man hier sagt, dass man sehr oft in die Toilette geht,
dann muss man sich etwas über das fragen.
Wie oft müssen sie in die Toilette gehen?
Wie viele Übrungen haben sie? Wie viele sind es?
Es bedeutet, dass man sehr oft in die Toilette geht.
Aber wenn man normal sagt, dass man es oft macht,
dann bedeutet das Poliure.
Man macht es normal, aber es geht sehr oft.
Wie oft müssen sie in die Toilette gehen?
Wie viele Übrungen haben sie? Wie viele sind es?
Wenn man selbst nicht fragt, ob man wirklich zu viel Wasser hat,
wie viele Übrungen haben sie?
Dann sagt man, dass man sich hier etwas über die Toilette sagen will.
Dann kommt man zu den Anamnesen der Foia-Krank.
Die Anamnesen der Foia-Krank sind wichtig.
Warum? Weil es hier die Diabetes-Mellitus und die Arterie-Hypertonis gibt.
Hier muss man sich die Anamnesen fragen.
Wenn man sich hier etwas über die Toilette sagt,
wenn man sich hier etwas über die Toilette sagt,
wie viele Übrungen haben sie?
Können sie regelmäßig ihren Blutz SMITHSEN?
Diese Diabetes-Mellitus tip.Tips外-Hastars
bekommt nur Mitformin,choose oftables.
Aber es kannемся immer entsprechend medidalos betrachtet werden.
rows spectral
Die Teststripe ist seit zwei Wochen vorbei, deshalb wurde sie nicht getestet.
Am Ende wurde sie von Hausarzt angestellt.
Da spricht Hemoglobin A1C, dem Hemoglobin C1A.
Er sagt, dass er hoch ist.
Dann die Arterie und die Hypertone.
Das ist die Masse des Regelmeissig-Iren-Boluttruck.
Das sind die Fragen.
Ich habe mich zuerst auf die Reaktionen angeschaut.
Ich habe mich immer gefragt, ob es so schnell geht.
Das tut mir leid, dass Sie so lange gewertet haben.
Aber wir sind im Notaufnehmen und haben viele Patienten.
Aber momentan kann ich mich um ihre Bechwerden kümmern.
Es ist sehr wichtig, regelmäßig den Blutzucker und Bluttruck zu messen,
damit wir das Problem so früh erkennen und eine bessere Therapie planen können.
Oder Komplikationen vermeiden können.
Ich werde Ihnen einige Teststreifen von der Polizei geben.
Dann können Sie das mit Ihrem Hausarzt sprechen.
Bluttruck ist nicht hier, aber in einem anderen Fall,
in Bernhardt, kann ich mir ein Tensionarbeiter schreiben.
Ich werde Ihnen die Frage stellen, ob Sie Bluttruck haben.
Natürlich, aber darüber werden Sie mit Ihrem Hausarzt sprechen.
Sie müssen mit Ihrem Hausarzt sprechen.
Aber ich werde Ihnen die Frage stellen, ob Sie Bluttruck haben.
Wir können das nicht in der Notaufnahme schreiben.
Ich glaube, das ist schon ganz logisch.
Ich habe die Patientin schon einmal gesehen.
Sie hat sich anstressiert.
Sie kann sich auch anstressieren.
Ich kann sie nicht anstressieren.
Es ist nicht logisch, eine Patientin zu folgen, die ich nicht anstresse.
Ich habe sie so anstressiert.
Ist es noch eine Reaktion?
Ich habe sie noch einmal gesehen, aber sie hat sie auch schon gesehen.
Wir haben die Reaktion von Drogge schon gesagt.
Ich habe noch etwas mehr gesehen, aber ich habe sie noch nicht gesehen.
Ich habe etwas vergessen.
Das ist ein ganzes Problem.
Ich glaube, es gibt andere Reaktionen.
Das ist normal.
Ist das normal hier?
Aber manche sagen, es ist eine Gevit-Sunahme.
Vielleicht gibt es eine solche Variation.
Es gibt auch die, die in den letzten Zeiten nicht 10 Kilo haben.
Das ist eine Gevit-Sunahme.
Das ist ein bisschen ein Gefühl.
Man kann sich das ansehen.
Wir können das ansehen.
Wenn es eine Situation mit der Situation gibt, können wir darüber sprechen.
Tümima, hast du dir das in der Therapie gemacht?
Ich schaue dir das in der Lab für Diabetes an.
Kannst du es für uns machen?
Die Diagnostik von Vartyre.
Ich kann es jetzt machen, weil es zu Ende ist.
Aber normalerweise habe ich meine Dokumente schon sendet.
Es gibt da etwas.
Ich habe die Diabetes Mellitus kontrolliert.
Und ich habe die Arterie und das Hyperton in der Form geschrieben.
Die Differenzialdiagnose ist Migraine und Tia.
Ich kann es auch so machen.
Was istvasаньas'
Tia?
Ich kann es so machen.
Und verified mit der Endogynologie?
aufgenommen werden. Die Patienten sollten Flüssigkeit zuvor, elektrische Substantien,
symptomatische Behandlung wie Anarchetika, Antiemetika erhalten. Wie ich gesagt habe,
werde ich einen Konsul in der Abteilung Endokrinologie anfordern. Je nach Befundem
wird eine Insulintherapie erforderlich sein. Ich glaube, ich würde das so machen.
Die Diabetes mellitus, also Blutgasanalyse, ist wichtig. Ist es eine Diabetes Ketoatestose
oder eine Hyperasmolare Koma? Es ist wichtig, das zu bezeichnen.
Blutgasanalyse, Labore verte, die Medikamente, die Diabetes Ketoatestose oder
Blutgasanalyse, Labore verte, die Medikamente, die Diabetes Ketoatestose oder Blutgasanalyse,
Blutgasanalyse, Labore verte, die Medikamente, die Medikamente, die Medikamente.
Ich habe mir eine ein paar neurologische Symptome ausgebildet.
Ich werde die anderen auch fragen.
Ich werde die beiden sagen, das habe ich mir geplant.
Vielen Dank.